[Music]
ah
wow that's the baddest man on earth
we're getting the uh
the belt out here
wow
that is beautiful that replica just
doesn't do it justice i tell you
wow
grab it fill the way
this is unreal
i'm getting goosebumps bro yeah
it's a weird day already this it's a
world heavyweight title
francis i've nicked your belt but i
don't i
don't want to fight you for it
welcome back to the true jordi podcast
you ready yes sir if the whole world was
to have a fight this guy would be the
last man standing it's the baddest man
on the planet the heavyweight champion
of the world
francis and garnier thanks for coming
thank you judy appreciate it
yeah i'm good man i'm good and uh you've
just came from the uh tyson fury fight
last night yeah uh where he won by
knockout in the sixth round dillian
white went down and then you get in the
ring afterwards and pick a fight with
them no i didn't think if i would well
he certainly uh seemed keen on the idea
oh yes the idea uh is clear that that
fight will happen i was there
in the ring cage last night to watch him
fight and it was a beautiful knockout
you know very clean the record you know
nobody couldn't see that coming perfect
but we have our own
little
statement to make we want to find out
who is the baddest
[__] on the planet damn right
yeah
he's a boxing champion in the world i'm
a mma champion of the world so
yeah
we can come together and see what is
their outcome you're talking about like
a hybrid fight between boxing and mma
sort of mma gloves are you thinking yeah
it could be it could be a mma globe uh
we haven't really think about it and how
uh it's gonna play out because first of
all we have a engagement with our uh
promotion right now so
i mean on on today unless they are they
they're on board we can really talk
about
about it like put out the term you know
now it's just some like uh
hope uh to get it done sometime next
year because anyway sometime next year
we're gonna be to the point to go
whether it's with or without our
promotions okay so the ufc for example
they've got you under contract until
early next year until late this year
late this year so yeah so
you're going to make that offer to them
you're either with me
or i'm doing it anyway yeah or i'm in
the ufc but they have to consider that
fight
you know to uh
to promote that fight for me
or to co-promote yeah
you've worked yourself into a fantastic
position
where most of the fighters never get to
because you were willing to keep
fighting on your original contract for
the same money
and
uh you bet on yourself in that last
fight even with an injury so that you
could be a free agent and do what you
want to do
uh a lot of people
they've never met managed that conor
mcgregor couldn't do it why did you
take that path what made you want to do
that freedom and free
you know you have to earned it
and
it wasn't about the last only about the
last fight people know more about the
last fight because that was the moment
that
uh i spoke about it and i always spoke
about it because like
my back was again the war
the ufc kind of like put me in that
position that i have to like defend
myself and tell people like no it's not
because i don't want to fight it's
because this is the this is the real
reason this is what is going on you know
i have to explain that would i didn't
want to do that you know like bring
stuff up i thought we're going to fix
then uh
in a behind the stage but behind the
stage i was getting bullied
and i didn't like that you know but it's
been a it's been uh over two years that
i've been working on this
since i realized that uh i am nothing i
have no say in my career um and i will
not never make any decision in my career
if i'm still in that contract
so i need to get out of that contract to
be able to like if even if
uh doesn't mean i don't want to be in
the ufc but i want to be in the position
a free position to negotiate a new
contract you know therefore i can speak
uh and uh claim my value my worth you
know but when you're negotiating in a
contract while you're staying in the
contract technically you're not
negotiating you're just like being
some sort of like submissive accepting
you know you have three fight uh left in
your contract in two uh two one or two
years
they have a right to extend it for maybe
two more years
oh no you're not negotiating anything
because whether you say yes or no you're
gonna fight so what is the point they
just offer you a little bit more money
you know and then
in this situation it takes a lot uh to
say no to the money because none of us
is like getting that much money you know
uh so it's very hard for a fighter on
this day to say no to a contract even
that no it's not good for them they have
to fight left or three fight they have
18 months left there is a possibility
that they can extend them with no
explanation no
no reason
a real reason and they cannot contest
that they cannot say anything about that
so when you kind of like think about
those stuff you're like this contract is
messed up this is not a contract this is
ownership i don't want to be owned by
somebody i just want to be free
and
if we keep working we can we can do it
as a partner i i see myself as a
business and my own business so i can
partner with other
business and work with them but nobody
and own me i'm the ceo of my own company
i mean you bang on you know you see what
they do to people like nate diaz for
example nate diaz is being held at the
moment he wants to fight jake paul you
know about nick diaz but it's the same
process for everybody and that's what's
been been going on you know uh if i
didn't speak about my own nobody would
have known
because uh yes they control the
narrative they have all the power uh for
everything
for the narrative media information uh
money
so they kind of like grow on uh
work
on people sometimes however have the ufc
been in touch since last night because i
can imagine
this would have sent shockwaves through
the business oh as a stranger you might
sound
we haven't hear from them funny that
right no they haven't been touched yeah
because they emailed you on the way to
your last fight if i'm right and
thinking about um
a situation like they threatened you
with a lawsuit
that was an empty uh
threat you know when i saw that
i told my manager like you don't have to
worry about this bro there's nothing
here
you know the thing is like um being
frustrated all the time being in this
situation and uh
i don't know if he ends up playing in my
favor because he get me to the position
that i'm like you know what i don't give
a [__]
you know whether it's a lawsuit or
whatever i don't give a [__] yeah you
know so when you get in that position
that you're thinking like that
that you're not afraid of anything
you know maybe sometimes you can that
can make you take a bad decision for
yourself but you don't care about
anything yeah
it's quite it seems quite poetic to me
that the guy they can't control with
money which is what they do with every
other fighter they dangle the carrot and
like people like jorge marsville for
example who've who've signed on and just
thought [__] i'm beaten i just need to i
just need to sign this contract and take
the money while it's there yeah but
you're the guy they couldn't control
with money and yet your history is
someone who has had less money than
anyone to start off with and so it's
almost like you kind of
look beyond the value of of of money and
it's more important
to get your worth and to feel
self-respect
in that situation maybe yeah i mean uh
don't get me wrong i love money
of course i'm fighting for it you know
i'm uh
i'm expecting to have as much money as i
could
but not at any cost you know um
one thing that is very important for me
and for somebody who like know a little
bit about my past i like freedom
i like to be set free i don't like to be
caged
doesn't matter what is in that cage i
don't want to be caged i run it because
you fight in a cage but
yeah i hear you
yeah it makes sense
yeah
yeah i don't like to be
stuck you know i like to be able to have
my shots i like to have options
as everybody should you know so um
in order to like have that freedom
sometime
you have to pay your due
i turned we turned down a lot of
money on contract in the past two years
contract negotiation because contract
negotiation technically
it's not really a negotiation it's just
like okay you take this much money
this more money and then you signed up
for
this much time again
you know you signed up for additional
time
so there's not a term that you're going
to go in that country try and negotiate
there's no like okay i want a full uh
healthcare
no that's out of option i want this oh
that's our option this is what we we get
you take or you don't take you know and
most of the time um
fighter since they don't have no choice
they're kind of like being uh
submits safe and i'm like okay let's
just take what i can take like
take let's take the money you know
but uh
no i couldn't i couldn't be in peace
with myself to do that i wouldn't be
i don't know i can't live with that
since i think about it so i'm like i'm
having what
i want at any cost
i respect that and i think they should
too and uh when you look at the business
as it's growing uh i looked recently at
the ufc 100 fighter pay
and jsp brock lesnar earning about the
same as what you were earning
in your last fight however that was
officially obviously there was a lot
more money in in the back end for those
guys but the point i'm making is in that
time the usa has grown
so much and they've they've then taken
fighter sponsorships away because
they've signed with respect what year
was that 2010 2009 2010 so about 12
years ago yeah and
it's not changed okay so when you think
about if you think about it financial
wise you will see like
somebody who was getting that amount of
money uh
that amount of money
12 years ago
worth like three times more today at
least if you invest that amount of money
in the property in the real estate or in
the business you will have been having
at least three times
if you take that
amount of money
uh
today wanna do something with it you're
gonna barely do one third of what you
could have done with that money in that
time
so it's not the same it's not the same
thing if you consider all this how
things is moving the business side the
inflection uh
the price the cost of living was on the
other side uh they can claim that too
but the problem is the business is
growing
it's not like they are asking somebody
to take
to pay out of his pocket
just a little part of the cake guys you
know
yes if there's nothing we all
starving we all staff is okay if there's
nothing but
what i'm saying is like when there's
something
just give maybe you know
no it's just a fair par uh part of the
kick
you know so
when you consider when you think about
all those i'm and that's like my problem
you know
yeah it's not my my business i didn't
build the ufc they did a in an amazing
job to build the company and i give them
credit for that i respect that i respect
that
but still today i think uh
as a fighter
i have a little bit of input or at least
a little i need a little bit of respect
maybe not much but a little bit
yeah because i believe that um
fighter make promotion of course yeah
you know like yes promotions do help
they do help each other but fight and
make promotion i don't like the idea
that without promotion fighting is
nothing no that's wrong
i would say i would
say without fighter promotion is nothing
because without a fighter who always
exists
there will always be a life having life
have a family
without fighting or without promotion
but promotion will never exist without
fighters and in in that time that we
were talking about from uh you know ufc
100 they've sold for four billion
they've got new sponsors in crypto and
other sporting brands and they've
stopped you fighters from wearing your
own spots or having your own sponsors
because those guy was having sponsored
that sponsor is a lot of it's a huge
problem today for the uh fighter and
it's very intriguing to see how they
have managed to get fighters out of that
i understand the fact that they want to
make the sport look good you know maybe
don't uh
make it uniform uh
for fighters
but the
they should at least
have
a certain amount of sponsor that every
fighter can put on his
gear because yet this is
fires source of revenue
whoosh has been taken from them by a
promotion because now it's not like they
are not putting anything they are
putting something on the
um
on the friday fighter geese
but
it has to be from the promotion so
unless it's from the promotion they
cannot put anything fighter cannot so
technically what do you have you have
nothing left you go there when you go
there you fight and you have nothing
they give you whatever they give you you
have to take in a ticket and say okay
thank you go back home and expect to get
call again if you don't get call
you don't get nothing you know you can't
even do your own business like recently
they signed a huge deal
from uh with the um crypto.com
that was a good deal for them
what for fire yeah
nothing right
but guess what that deal take
money out of my pocket at least one
million
wow
because so you had a competitive brand
offer you our we had a competitive uh
offer from uh
coinbase okay
and then when crypto.com
announcement came out i'm like listen
guy
we can do this
what do i get about the crypto deal
nothing i just have to wear my gears
with a big head crypto.com in front of
it i don't have any say i don't have any
money about it but
they don't even think about it they
don't even mention it if i have my
sponsor if i say okay i have my sponsor
i want to put this on my shirt
no
it's even out of option you know you
don't even have a right to say it
which is something that i don't agree
with i think it's not it's unfair for
fighters uh considering how
low fighters are getting paid they
should get
some right
you know they should at least
have a space on the shorts that everyone
can use sort of thing yeah like okay we
don't want to anything they don't want
everything to appear on the tv we get
that but at least they can have a
a department to approve a sponsorship if
you say okay i have a sponsor they'll be
like okay let's check if he fits
in something that we can let him
appear on the tv you know yes
i'm i'm good with that
they can uh disagree with some sponsor
because yes they are not good looking
they know they don't stand for the value
of fighting or for the sport
i agree with that but at least get that
option there it feels like they've built
the business like a team or like an mba
team or or nfl brand but they're still
they're not treating you guys like
actual players of the team so
they're not paying you what they're
doing is so treating you like boxers so
like we are assets yeah so you get none
of the you get none of the benefits and
all of the [__] yeah
but i think you know i think uh i've
been thinking i and i think the reason
is because fighter doesn't have anybody
to speak for for them they don't have a
union not even a union
let's think about this
most of the time
i will i mean i never been in the ball
meeting of a company of a big company
but let's just uh speculate
they are in the bond meeting
of a company what do they do
they think for the benefit of a company
that's how every business work right
so
if in other hand fighter is out there
and they don't have nobody to represent
them
so who would think for the fighter most
of the time they would take this
decision which is good for them they
don't even intend to hurt fighter
but he ends up hurting fighter
you know so in my perspective
i think they should at least have like a
fighter
not a union but a fighter representation
in the ball meeting when they took some
sort of decision that guy would be there
to like listen guy what about us you
know what about fighter we think this
should be good
and uh
i think that way
things could get better you know because
i i
truly believe that everything that is
bad for fighter
is not like uh necessarily a decision
that they did on purpose to hurt fire
sometimes they just don't think about it
they just ignore it or
just think about it they're under
pressure as well because they were
bought by wma
and they're expected to deliver profits
now that's not a problem you expect to
do whatever you want to do but remember
you're in the business with somebody
who does some we we are expecting to
fight are expecting to do something else
we are expected to pay our loan we are
expecting to send our to sit
put the put food on the table we are
expecting to have
our family her insurance to put them uh
in the safe place
we are expecting a lot of things so
i mean everybody has the expectation in
his life everybody has something that he
wants
you know you just have to like
compromise and see what is doable for
each of them
i think that's how things should be i
mean for example you're sponsored by
gymshark and
you can't wear officially i assume you
can't wear it on the tv when you're like
you can't you can they will check even
your underwear
on the backstage good luck to whoever
checks your underwear yes to see if
there's nothing else wow like
everything they will check and you're
one of the lucky few who's managed to
secure a sportswear deal
that you can wear outside of the octagon
but like you say with your crypto issue
most fighters the minute a company hears
we can't be seen on the ufc well there's
no point we go directly to the ufc we
give them the money and it makes the ufc
have all the power and then the ufc call
you
i'm like okay we have a great deal for
you this is what we have and maybe
it's
five percent of that what they take from
the for the sponsor
on your behalf i'm like oh we can get
him for this amount of money they call
you they give you five percent of that
yeah you won or you don't want
is a great deal you have no option it's
not like you have a lot of deer on the
table you have a lot of choice and this
is this is partly why you want to fight
tyson fury i'm assuming because
you know you've got that freedom and you
can make so much money together and you
can secure your future i don't
necessarily agree with that i don't say
this is partly why this is partly why i
don't want to sign a new contract on
that term uh i can still be in the
contract with the usa and 5000 fury and
keep fighting with in the ufc you know
uh
and i always envision things like that i
always think that when comes the moment
uh we will
it will be something that the usa can
step up and co-promote
you know and then after maybe tyson fury
i will go back keep fighting i don't
know fight john jones or
feisty pay again or
you know okay all those things you know
it's not like it's the end of my career
i'm not like a one fight out of the game
they're worried about that though maybe
like let's let's play devil's advocate
okay so with conor mcgregor yeah he was
already off to the moon they couldn't
hold him back so they had to kind of
give in to the mayweather fight because
it was it made so much sense for them
money-wise but with you
you are in that period where your your
your star is growing but you're you're
not as big as what you would be
if you went and fought tyson fury so
what they're probably thinking is if we
don't let them fight tyson fury
we can keep him just a little bit less
of a star and therefore he's more
affordable he's still our champion and
we win so
could that be their logic
and that's the idea that i don't wanna
i'm fighting i don't wanna even uh think
about that possibility
why because if you think you have to do
something to stop me of doing what i
want i mean what is the freedom here
what are we talking about where is the
freedom
what is the definition of a freedom
you know that might be what i want it's
my choice
that's my i might just go there and
fight i'm like oh i'm not fighting again
it's my choice
i have a right to do that you understand
so the only thing that you can do is to
figure out how
to change my mind or how to work
together in whatever i want to do
that's how it works it's not like you
intend to change the course of my life
in your benefits i don't think they
promoted your last fight very well for
example i don't think that i don't feel
like they want you to be the biggest
star you can no because that because
they don't want because i i'm not
control that
they can't control me
you know i'm not the guy that i don't
want to see
you know
well i mean let's take for example the
belt moment you get the belt put on you
and for what is probably the first time
ever dana white doesn't put the belt on
a champion this is the first time in my
memory
how did that feel for you because it was
a clear
you know i was busy i don't know if he
was delivering a baby or putting out a
fire but he should have been there to do
that for you and yet he still wasn't
there so what how did that make you feel
if you were me how would you feel i felt
i would feel pissed off really yeah i'd
be like
treat me with the same respect that you
trust the last hundred years let me tell
you something yeah i feel happy
you know why okay because that means i
make my point that's me and i it kind of
like understand what i was saying what i
was fighting for oh yeah you're afraid
now i guess
no
he was unhappy and he couldn't control
me yeah and he get pissed off because
thing didn't go his way
he wanted god to win clearly
he wanted cyril gone to beat you guess
what happened
you wrestle the [__] out of him they're
lost are we
so that means technically yes yeah if
that's the case that mean
he
he as well
lost us
gun that night right so i was a winner
why should i be pissed off very true
i mean how did you have a conversation
with dana after this about your plans
and and how was that conversation if so
yeah we had a dinner he was a little
weird
because there was a
you know lately we haven't been having a
healthy relationship as you got as well
seen and you said yourself
um he was very clear that
he's not happy with my situation
so um i think he was just like to clear
things out like to clear the air because
in
the where we are i think in order to
move forward we have to like express
something out and get off our
frustration
he's he's probably frustrated as
well about something as i am
you know we need to uh clear that out i
don't think we're just gonna sit down
and just stop contract like normal yeah
because like personally
i can live pretty good without contra
without fighting you know and i think
this is the um
this has always been this is even the
reason why i'm here
i never let anything control me i never
let the narrative change the course of
my life or what people believe changed
the course of my life i never let let
the situation that i am in uh
affects my dream you know so that's why
i believe in myself and i believe in
whatever
i
i do whatever i want to do whatever is
my dream i always believe in it i didn't
have a chance to go to school i didn't
even go to high school i didn't go to
college but i believe that if i i can
become a huge businessman tomorrow as
that is my dream i believe that if i
want to play another sport that i never
practice in my life i would just go
there restart over and then do it i'm
not here because i win by somebody vote
because somebody hired me because
somebody selected me
i'm here because i end the position so
if i earn that position that means i
have some sort of skill some ability to
go from
to start over and get there so i could
start over
there i want that list the lesson that i
took from my life is that
i can always start over i'm not afraid
of start over even though i want to
continue growing but if it happened that
i have to start over
for some reason maybe just the
circumstances of life
i'm not afraid i know
that i can start over and still make
things happen i think
today that's like the
the big my biggest value my biggest
strength that's my worth
you know is that
ability to start to always start over
because i've been complaining from for
many times i was i've been complaining
about my life my childhood my days how
many times i have fell on how things
never work out for me
until someday i realize that
if i fail anytime that means
i restart every time
you know so i i restart over and over
over and over because believe me if you
fail if you fall and don't stand up you
won't fall again if you fall and stay on
the ground you will never fall
if you fall many times that means you're
standing up and there's a good spiral
i think that's kind of indicative of
your fight and style as well though like
you are a risk taker in the octagon and
ironically i felt last night watching
dillian white versus tyson fury that
there wasn't enough of that from dillian
white i think he needed to pull the
trigger and go out there and try and
make this into a fight and i know you
will do that if you fight tyson fury
you've got you haven't got the fear that
other people seem to have a failure
about that fight i would think yes you
have to take a risk but also have to be
smart
i think uh
maybe he didn't just have options maybe
he tried so hard and it didn't work
but um
yeah uh
i'm a risk taker i like
risk
because the best thing always happen in
the higher risk the more you risk
the highest the reward you make a good
player
um yeah
so dana uh recently uh was talking about
you having a big ego
and obviously you've got self-confidence
but it's due to what you've been through
in your life did you hear that quote
about him
complaining about francis has got a head
so big these days and did you hear any
of that you have to understand that
every time that you get off the line
in this type of situation
you have to you're going to face a
problem you know not because you're
wrong you have a guy that has uh
hundreds of fighter on his control and
over the years he have deal with
thousands of fighters
and you came you think different you say
no to things that maybe everybody says
yes
you say no to stuff that
nobody really said that to him
yeah i mean that's having an ego right
i think you also think like that
and
i do have an ego
i mean
i don't have a problem with you i'm very
happy with my ego because my ego is what
once again put me here like i look at
myself i'm like oh i'm better than that
guy that's why i'm a champion
if you if you are not able to look at
yourself and look other man in the eyes
doesn't matter how strong he is i'm like
i'm gonna take this guy down you know i
mean just calm down francis
if you don't have that
no you better just change yeah your job
i mean you can't be heavyweight trump
into the world without having that you
can be a champion in whatever you're
doing
without having that belief
believing i mean believe in yourself is
kind of like technically like what they
would say some people will say ego
you know like no i'm good no you're
wrong to say i will not make it oh yes
you fell
it's okay but i will make it that's
eager yeah you know dana white's got a
massive eagle i mean how else can you he
should have eaten all those fighters and
and build a business like that you need
an eagle yeah you should have it ego
yeah of course and and interestingly
in the ufc we were i dana white's job is
to give the fans the best fights
possible and the fight we all wanted
was jon jones versus francis ingarnu and
it felt like you two kind of had a bit
of an agreement together at one point
where you said we don't fight until we
get the money we want and he could have
resigned you
for that fight if they'd put the money
on the table for you guys it felt
but he didn't deliver and we're
two years in we haven't seen jon jones
for god knows how long they're now
setting up the steep air fight
does that fight interest you the
potential jon jones fight absolutely as
i said i think i still have a
many fight ahead of me
and john jones was one of it
and
that was two years ago almost two years
ago
that i call out jon jon and really want
that fight even before the stippy fight
you know uh because i always want that
fight i always think that would be a
very uh interesting fight beautiful
fight
you know and once again i get frustrated
how things were
going because no it wasn't just about
like having a good fight it's about
having a fight on their term like
we will just give you
a good fight as you were saying like you
will fight olefi tyson fury
if we can control you
if we control everything
if we kind of like think we don't
control anything everything
if
we think that you're asking like maybe
a good part of the cake or a let's say
fair power part of the cake
no it won't happen you we want you to
understand
who uh
make the call here
you know so at that point i dropped it
i'm like okay
i don't want this to be something
uh
i don't want this to be a
leash
to control me the john john fight that's
why at some point i'm like i'm not
interested in it
of course i'm interested in john john
fight but i don't want that john john
fight to be something
would come with it with a price
you know to control me
how do you say that fight going if it
happens against john jones because in
his last few fights at light heavyweight
he didn't look great he was getting a
little bit slower very close fights and
i think for me uh he's going to be very
good because john jones he looked a
little slower and
as a
in the past two years he's been putting
some weight on trying to
be heavy to come fight at heavyweight
and i think that won't make it any fast
yeah
and also like it light heavyweight he's
had a massive size and reach advantage
on almost every opponent aside from one
or two
so this would be
exciting as a fan of mma to see him
tested against men his size in terms of
frame and i think that would be
i think it'll be a rough night for him
uh you know like though too yeah i think
it's gonna be a rough night uh john john
is very tough he's very talented
but um
it's gonna be a rough night for yeah
we've seen him get hit by uh
machida and other guys who you know were
light heavyweight middleweights but you
are
as i've experienced like when you walked
in the room i was like oh [__]
bigger than i thought even you know what
i mean you're a massive guy
i just want to see you in the in the
octagon in the ring competing
um i'll be back next year
2023 will be
will be my best year yet
you know i'm coming back uh
i'll be coming back from a surgery and
it's gonna be a year that i'm gonna do a
boxing fight maybe do some
i don't know some good one or two mma
fight
maybe two one another one boxing fight
you know so
i'm very excited about 2023 it might be
a year my my biggest year the biggest
year of my career because i might be
fighting
three or four times that year in two
different sports
and if you've had your knee injury how
is how is that going with the knee right
now it's going pretty good it's been
five weeks and uh
everything looks perfect
the surgeon was very happy
after the surgery and i saw him three
days ago
and he was so very satisfied with the
result how things are going physical
therapy is going very good uh i've been
working with out clutches for almost two
weeks now so everything is going pretty
good and i think like uh
in two or three months i'll be able to
like at least start to hit like a part
of staff because i will be able to twist
uh to pivot on that
knee if on that leg again and i will
start training
so
by uh
september
i will really be
able to like go in the full
calm if uh if the ufc just said flat out
no we're not going to allow you to box
obviously you've said your box anyway do
you think you may do an mma fight in a
different organization
and fight with a bellator for example
would you consider it
yeah
i consider fighting
i mean
on this day you know everything is
possible
once again i'm not a guy that um
i don't want to put
all my eggs in one basket
i want to look around and see what's
possible and when i look around
it's a land of opportunity
everything is laid down there you just
have to have it right look
at it
like let me be um
hypothetically i particularly like
let's say
i don't
get to a grand agreement with any
organization what will happen
why
maybe i will just go fight for
my own organization i mean that's
possible right
what is the problem what what did it
take to have a promotion well khabib's
just started one and i had uh israel
arasanya on the show recently
and i mentioned because i've i've also
had oozman so you're i'm completing the
three kings today you know it's my third
case where i was going legend and i was
thinking you know khabib's doing
something in russia maybe you guys could
set up something in africa or something
like that absolutely yeah the tricking
promotion how does that sound amazing
do we need somebody a commentator we
will just uh
raise money and
of course
a promotion there yeah and we have a and
i have an idea i've been working on it
um
i think we're just gonna have like a uh
doubt
you know raise money from
a community that would be like
controlling
the uh the promotion so it won't be like
somebody somebody decide what to do
right every time that you think about
something you're gonna bring it on the
table and they decide you know make
something in like a crypto
or
something different
the uh
demographic of today the three you have
probably inspired so many athletes in
africa to try combat sports you know i
mean what is it
what does it feel like to be an idol
it feels good
but uh i would say
you will feel better
if you
use that in the proper way if you
utilize that so like maybe build more
opportunity or do some stuff because yes
we are tricking
but uh still
that yes that inspires some people but
still that still doesn't give them
opportunity
we are in the position that we can like
easily
give or bring some opportunity back home
to our
people
you know
maybe some uh
organization like that we won't just
take
just
take some
eyeballs and bring it out there
and it will be a good opportunity
for people out there for fighter will
maybe one uh one day making in the ufc i
do believe that they can have uh
we can have african promotion good
enough for african
and uh to satisfy everybody
and don't make them
put their life in risk to go in europe
or whatever you know to try and create
those crazy stuff
just be there and uh yeah and keep the
ecosystem going yeah i mean it's it's so
strange that they haven't done more over
there with uh
you know the muhammad ali story and what
he did
that's part of
the
the problem as well because yes um
for a long time i've been like okay how
can we have a ufc in africa how we want
a ufc in africa and i still i still want
ufc and africa yeah
but
when i i kind of like think about it i'm
like a long time ago one of the biggest
event in the combat sport was
rambo indiango
was in africa
he was
great he was big he was massive
but how did that
benefit people there
what was the outcome
[Music]
the many decades after
what is the benefit of that in the
community
you know and i can't see any of that
so
in my perspective i think that was a
wrong
that was a wrong idea we imported
something big
rather than cr started our own thing
even if it's small at that time
the time that we have they have a
rainbow in the jungle in africa less
let's just say
at that time with that money debut
multiple facility in that country
boxing gym
one or two arena because that was a huge
amount of money for that country they
could have built like
one of two arena build like five or ten
gyms in the country
and then kind of like promote the sport
for the youth by today
that country will be having at least
three world champion and the ecosystem
there will be so big
that they won't they need to like travel
or they won't need other organizations
and that's what how i'm looking at mma i
don't just want to bring like okay one
big event
who does it belong
to our you want to build infrastructure
we can create more in the future yeah
yes we can build out of it we can build
a small
we will belong with the ownership we
belong to us
and we will grow over time in 10 years
from now
he will just be growing
and impacting on kids you know
generation after generation because it's
gonna be a whole in ecosystem we're
gonna you when you have a fighter
when you have a star
you have tv when you have tv
you have a sponsor
company
when you have sponsor you have company
there is money and when those fighters
have money they provide to their family
they need services
they need maybe driver they need daycare
and then this ecosystem they are taking
money and
put it in in the economy that's how they
build the country
that's how they build a ecosystem i
wanna i wanna go back to your home and
tell me what it was like growing up
so very often i would say oh it was hard
and he was
you know
[Music]
but once again
i think that's a part of my life that's
a that was something that i needed
because like
i have a very difficult childhood
and i can
we can stay here all day long i will be
explaining telling you what
went wrong like um
how i couldn't
just have a normal life at as other kids
because i couldn't have pen or book or
have a scholarship a scholarship taken
care by my parents and all those staff
who was very hard on me and very
frustrating very
[Music]
very hard how old were you when you left
i was 26
20 okay
[Music]
okay so you're still very young then and
would you uh are gonna give
a credit to my past to that child who
was very tough because he forces me he
taught me in the hard way
you know to have to deal with myself to
be on my own to don't have to to don't
to not rely on people
just by not having anybody
why i need it you know
you don't feel a lot of loyalty no
because there wasn't
nobody at all relying on
you know uh
when you can have
when even your parent can help you
not because they don't want or just
because they can
then
i mean
as a kid you kind of like understand
that you have to you have to walk your
ass off oh you know otherwise
it won't be easy for you you know you
don't realize
that it's kind of like
education
you know
i think if everything was
perfect for me
as a
kids i wouldn't be here and i wouldn't
be uh having this perspective of life
yeah because
i would have been
maybe uh
rely or expect something from somebody
or from life you know but i have a tough
life who taught me to like
not expect anything from anybody you're
on your own
you know and then when you
pick that up and like okay this is how
it is guess believe me you won't get
disappointed
at all
but does that not make it a bit hard to
develop connections with other people
now because you've come from a place
that is very different to where you are
now so you've gone from no one giving a
[__]
to now everyone wants to kiss your ass
does that does that make it hard to find
figure out what's real and what's not
there's a little bit of both you know uh
first of all as i say even about my
parents it's not like they didn't it's
not like they didn't give a [__] it's
just like they couldn't do anything
you know even those who care couldn't do
anything at all
so the situation the uh the life there
uh was so miserable
anybody couldn't do anything
my mom was always there
but
sometimes she was just powerless most of
the time
but she was there
but uh
yeah he make it very difficult to come
to your point
uh
after my parents get divorced i was six
years old i started live in a different
houses
did go to different family
and then trying to have friends
uh trying to be a part of that family
and then was always like you know kind
of like uh rejected or something at
school at home at school because i
didn't have a i was always a new kid i
didn't have a k a friend from home that
would go to school together so i get to
school i don't know any kids whether
it's my neighbor or not i don't have any
friend at school any friend base
so
he gets
very tough
and my situation
didn't have i mean the fact that at
school um they will point me out amongst
other kids to be the one that didn't
have a the one that doesn't have a
pen to take note okay not book or the
one that hasn't paid a scholar fee so
they're gonna kick me out in front of
other kids so yes therefore you are not
a good profile to be a friend nobody is
excited to be friend with that guy
you know
so
despite my effort to be
friend to her friend he was very hard
and by the time that you you're close to
like maybe build something else have
some relation with some kids then you
have to move again go someplace and
start over
so i kept i kept trying and i think at
some point i just like unconsciously
give up like okay
this might just be my life i just have
to wrap this around my mind
you know and just accepted it
but
i remember like being a child i kind of
like have a
virtual war in my mind
a war with a perfect family
with my mom and dad at home that i could
have everything that we could have eat
three meals a day
you know easily go to school have
friends go back home
like that was in my mind and like when
it was so hard for me i could escape and
go take a time
go in that wall who was just in my mind
virtual and he was so perfect good
enough to escape
you know that's why like today uh
no long time ago i heard about something
that said metavis i'm like what is
nervous they're trying to understand how
like that's look very familiar to me
yeah you had your own memory i have i've
been having that my entire life i have
my mirror verse with me
man you're a legend yeah so after all
that oh christ you know i get used to
not have friend
and didn't even have a desire to try
anymore because i get used to
then i get to a point but nobody noticed
that you don't have a friend nobody
noticed that
you're just a lonely guy you just want
to be by yourself you know
until the day that somebody wants
to be with you
then you find out that you are not so
friendly you are not how he
expected you or how he wanted you to be
then you are not a good guy
guess what i always been like this you
know you didn't just give a [__]
you didn't just know me
you know
now i understand maybe you want to know
me
but this is who i am
some people will be like oh you change
oh you this
screw you i didn't change you didn't
just know me before
because if you knew me before you knew
that how i was you know because before i
was like that today i'm like i'm like
this today but before i was like that so
technically i didn't change okay i've
got two questions because this is
fascinating okay i feel like i'm
learning a lot more about you here
so
personally
i i didn't come from having money in the
uk i came from a you know working class
place but now i've got money sometimes i
think back to the money struggles that i
used to have
and wish
i had the money
like i had the money i've got now back
then do you ever think about that or is
it just not something you even
worry about anymore i don't wish to have
um
to go back in the past first of all i
can't do anything in the past the only
thing that i can do
is the uh for the present and the future
that's the only thing that i can
control but if for somehow i have a time
machine to go back i won't go back
you know
because i i
strongly believe that the fact that i
knew
poverty
and that situation
make me appreciate what i have today the
life that i have today even better
and have a different perspective of life
when you see somebody who come from a
decent family or from a rich family he
has a different perspective and he might
be having a ton of money but there is
something in life that he will never
never understand
you know i have a opportunity i had the
opportunity
to learn that to understand that even
though it was in the hard way and uh
without that
i wouldn't be what i am today
me being rich today once again is not
about money i think is my life
experience my life experience for me is
a like one of the biggest
thing that i value the more who has a
more value i kind of like understand
people different situation
i go here i go back home i see i hang
out with rich people
and i
i understand their problem
and i see them
what they are facing as a problem i
understand that i i go there i see poor
people i understand them i understand
everyone i'm able to assimilate all
those
rich people doesn't understand poor
people poor people doesn't unders poor
people don't don't understand rich
people but i understand both
clearly because i've been in both sides
i can't think for both of them you know
i like that that's great yeah it's a
great way of looking at it and also like
you said that you went from a guy who
was
a bit of a law now a guy who didn't want
to be everyone's friend because of how
you've been treated but now
the people the ufc fans we see you as a
very friendly gentle giant to people
when you're not in the cage so did you
make changes and how did those changes
happen with your personality
being friendly and being respectful is
too thin different
i mean i will respect you
that doesn't mean i want to hang out
with you i want to sit down and watch
movies with you but we are couple yeah
you know but i think respect i have to
respect
everybody
first of all
you know whether i like you or not that
doesn't matter
i have to respect you as a person
because that what i'm expecting from you
to respect me in return
you know that's only what i think i
deserve from you
you have a right to like me or not
that's your right
i won't blame you for that
love is a feeling but respect is a duty
speaking of love uh what's uh what's
francis's uh love life like what does i
mean
i mean now you've got women coming after
you surely what what's that like being
the champ you know must be good
life has always been good
[Music]
yes
my guy
i like it life have always been good
that's always been good not right it's
always about perspective yeah
freedom it's what he wants it's always
about prospections
um okay is there a is there a
is there a type of woman that francis
looks for and is like that's my kind of
woman any anything
okay how about this good one mate a good
woman okay is there any celebrity women
who you'd be like that's my
celebrity crush do you have a celebrity
crush or anything i had a celebrity
crush when i was a kid oh tell me
jennifer lopez
oh of course
she's amazing bro
yeah i think you can still make that
happen you know i think oh yeah
like just punch better reflect even when
they're told bet off like if you're
watching we won't all right even when
that um they always say oh you should do
dance off with the star i'm like i'm
doing dance uh with the star only with
jello there you go that's it that's it
the terms are set you gotta negotiate
all right
uh i i like it man i like it and and
obviously so we've we've we've talked a
bit about your upbringing and how you
became the person you are but why why
fighting
what was it that fighting did for you
what feeling did you get that you just
wanted to do more of
i love finding since i was kids um that
was my passion um everything that i
could have
done and enjoyed was like watching movie
or like playing those
uh
game
like go out there in the
banana uh
banana frame from and just kick and
punch those banana tree onto the fare
down
and even though i was getting beat up
after i won't but i was always do it
again and again and again and not uh
even kids around they didn't want to
play with me first of all i didn't have
friends if you were kicking the tray
down i'm not surprised
banana trees
off
so
i grew up in cameroon so we have a
culture of a soak of soccer yeah or
football yeah so everyone want to play
soccer i was playing soccer but most of
the time if i would have to choose it
would have been like something like
fighting stuff and they didn't like it
for them that was violent
you know
so much when you tried to get people to
play with you yeah they'd be like no
we're playing football bro yeah so that
was the first that was the first reason
like me with fighting it was since i was
a kid
you know okay but um
growing up like having my dad uh
he was so strong because in my family we
have
uh that reputation my fa that was so
strong that was strict fighter
you know was fighting at the street at
the bar
bar everywhere
so um he didn't have a good reputation
so um
i kind of like i was kind of like
ashamed of my dad so why ashamed
because he have this reputation of being
a street fighter like firing people and
people i'm like oh that guy oh you know
then i'm like uh i don't want people to
talk about me like this
wow so he's
the genetics of him and probably what he
had in him is now
part of you now and that's part maybe
why i had the same thing yeah but didn't
just want to go the same way
and i do believe that
because he was there to show me maybe
not the way to go but the way not to go
because from my dad
i really
like seeing my dad or
hearing people talking about my dad
i was just six years old when the
divorce and then i went to i started i
we moved
and people started to talk about my dad
because when i was with my dad i didn't
realize that basically i was at six
years old
so
they started talking about my dad
then i saw i just feel so
ashamed of it then i'm like i don't want
to become like that
that was the first thing oh you know
your dad passed away is that correct
yeah yeah he passed away that was in
2001. so how how was it to deal with
losing him were you okay or was that
difficult or
he was difficult but he's not like we
have many choice you know in africa
stuff like that happen more often you
you lose people
[Music]
yes he was hot i mean every kid's that
basically when you love your dad and you
lose him
you know he's not like your happiness
i am but you have to deal with it life
is moving on i hope you don't mind but
yes i seen you posted a picture of him
this was a while ago yeah and i actually
uh i restored it i tried to restore it
for you so that you could see it
properly
wow so there's an app that that helps
you basically be able to see the faces
more clearly from the photograph i sent
you the changes ago this one look
yeah
it looks very clear than what i have
yeah i thought it would help you so that
you could see him a bit clearer
thank you no problem i didn't um yeah
this picture was like an old picture
that somebody gave me
i sent you that
it's clear
it's very clear yeah
what is the app
uh i'll i'll find out i can't remember
what the name of it is okay send you
it's good i like to play with it yeah
it's fun like get your old photographs
and uh refresh them and stuff yeah um
in terms of fighting yeah coming into
the ufc
uh
what we what we noticed about you that
was very different to
any other fighter was obviously your
power your striking but also that
willingness to
go for it and and to go for the kill
was that just always in you as a kid and
why is it that that's your style do you
think
i think whatever you do in life
uh
you have to do it best and in order to
do it best
uh there is not
such a thing like a motivation the
reason why you do it
like i will find people whom like we
will be like oh i want to do uh
mma i want to do this and uh
i'll ask them why
somebody will say oh because i wanna
i like you to you you guys are famous
you guys are this uh i want a nice car i
wanted this i'm like bro
find something else
because it won't be easy
you know if that's your motivation it
won't be enough you don't walk to that
uh
how they call it um
hot door that aisle walking to the arena
thinking about
the car that you're gonna buy or
whatever you're gonna do that's not
motivation
you know when you wake up and
doesn't want to don't want to go to
practice
you don't think about stuff like that
and even if you think about it
i'm like ah i have a car either way you
know
you need a motivation you need something
we will kick you off uh your bed your
bed
when you don't want to when you want to
stay you know and what is that for you
so finding first of all like what's my
everything you know i put my everything
i invest my everything in that like
nobody ever believed
in me in in basically in fighting when i
came
up with the idea of fighting
in cameroon i sounded crazy
literally like they wanted to throw me
in the uh
uh
psychiatric center like dumb like this
kid is losing his mind or
like we can't stop him from
thinking about that thing
you know
so again i went against their their ways
so i put everything in for my family at
that point i was for some point i was
just a bad guy a stubborn kid that
couldn't listen to what they was telling
him
but i believe in something i believe
that is going to work and i believe that
the day that it works
um
they will agree with me you know i have
to prove them wrong
and that was the only thing that i had
uh didn't have a job didn't have a
college college degree couldn't
maybe have a proper job
you know
uh
was still looking back from my family
that was hoping that okay oh he has made
it in europe so maybe he would could
help us
you know
was hoping that i can provide for them
or assist them when they need a
um
when somebody is sick and want to go to
the hospital may they don't stay at home
uh as my dad did because i
believed that if
with money my dad could have stayed a
few more years my dad got sick and
didn't have the money to go to the
hospital
and uh i didn't want that to happen and
i think that was always one of my fear
like okay what will happen
if
my mom got sick and i will be there and
powerless you know so i need to do what
it takes everything that i have to do to
be able to like assist people that i
care for you know when i could so all
those things together like
was my motivation at first like when i
was walking to the octagon
sometime you know i just think of what
i've been through how i get here
bro you have to kill me
you know
i'm not coming there to
play with you i'm coming there to fight
but i'm not fighting you i'm fighting my
life i'm fighting whatever is wrong in
my life
you know i'm fighting whatever can be a
problem in my family that i have to
solve
i'm fighting for a solution
for my family
i'm fighting for my kids not to be not
to ever
go to what i've been through not to
not even know what he looks like
you know because yes uh i don't want to
change that but still i don't want my
kids to experience that i can look at
them go to that kind of life you know so
that was the reason
yeah i think those motivations are
stronger
very strong and
we've never really seen anyone attack
people the way you do and i put it like
that because it really doesn't feel like
they want to fight sometimes when you
start swinging at them like that rosen
strike fight you know that i think was
like 20 seconds 10 seconds something
like that he lasted god bless him
uh once you started swinging for me i'm
watching that fight no that that fight
was was different
because i was full of frustration i mean
it looked that way yeah that was the
moment that uh
even with the ufc i was very frustrated
and that was getting me
you know so i kind of like
i didn't know that he was getting me
onto that fight and now i'm like this
thing is
gonna take over me i better control this
so that was like full of frustration
yeah you you
god damn you you let that out like
because i i've never seen anyone do
anything like that fight in the ufc to
memory you know like this this guy did
not stand a chance and he is a very good
fighter you know he's a hard guy but
when i was just wondering was there rage
within because it looks that was the
rage oh yeah there was a really oh wow
okay because you you you seem to have
you've evolved as a fighter so much and
now we're seeing you can you know even
with the ufc and everything you went
through in the last fight against steep
a you controlled yourself um sorry the
fight before the last one again stephen
you were so controlled and patient and
how did you master that emotionally
try practice you know try to think about
it
calm myself down don't let anything
control me it's freedom
be free
said as a free man yes
i like that because when you have like a
rare
rage or angry he controls you
very true yeah yeah when you're free
you're in peace with whatever
is on how often do you introduce do you
get annoyed and angry does that happen a
lot or no yeah no when was the last time
you got a bit pissed off at someone or
something or you know i'll get a little
piss off of stuff time to time but
really quick like nothing nothing like
it would take a minute for me to like
whatever
you know do you ever do you think you
intimidate people
yeah
do you think you ought to compensate for
that then and try and be nice to try and
make people feel
less intimidated yes that's what i do
like
uh when i first get in paris uh you know
in cameroon i didn't have this problem
but i went in paris
and then i was a
bouncer in the nightclub
so
most of the time
basically around 3 4 5 a.m people will
come to me
i'm like bro you're scary
you can smile or something like you're
just caring
you know
and then i'm there i'm tired my back
hurts
i just want to get out of there and they
are drunk come on like
some people will come
i just want to get out of there uh-huh
you know then i realized that
i was intimidating and then i'll have a
lot of like comment from people that we
are like friends now that will tell me
like oh the first time that i met you
was in this place oh you scared the hell
out of me i'm like really what happened
i'm like you you never see yourself walk
like you you was working like this and i
was coming in the same side and
i just think you're gonna like
smash me or something you know i'm like
why would i smack
i'm like you just looks like
you know
so now
therefore like
if i find myself with somebody
coming in the same side in distance
i know that that person might be
intimidated by me so i will cross
like to make the person feel free yeah
safe i'll do a little bit of the same
like like okay there's no trap i'm
walking away you know because even
though i'm i'm not going to do anything
or i'm not intending to do anything to
him they will get intimidated but i
didn't know that at first and people was
freaking out
what was it like being a bouncer in
in france well a friend
held me
getting that job because first of all i
didn't have a paper paper
so i couldn't work technically
and that was like one of the only job
that i can sneak and work yeah and they
pay me in cash so i can i could survive
with yeah you know so but but he wasn't
the job that i wanted to do he was just
so perfect because it was only the
weekend and during the week
i could have trained all day long
and then the weekend go
find some job get some money do you ever
have a drunk guy uh try uh try to fight
you we get that i get that once wow he
wasn't a guy he was a group of guy tell
me uh how many i don't know four or five
wow okay and then uh what happened well
i think the smoke in the club
and then
we sent we sent them out and then they
went down the street and wait for us for
me
like after the club was closed okay i
was walking by and they just come like
very close and you know
like there wasn't very drunk but you're
like okay this is trouble
i have to step away i have to get out of
here you know and then we just pick up a
fight and my colleague from the other
side he saw it he came but he wasn't
just like fighting to like okay stop
them like you're literally like
kicking somebody
like in the head i'm like bro
i don't want to get involved in this we
better stop this right now okay so the
two of you beat the [__] out of them
basically yeah
there was more than there was like five
but
there was a group of ten people but
there were girls and someone didn't want
to fight you know
and the police came
and uh
took them like
ask them if we want to press us also if
we want to press charge
because apparently the police car wasn't
far so technically
i think they saw
how he uh began oh and uh they asked if
we want to press charge i'm like no just
want to go home
you could have been involved in like
bouncers get
you know roped into a lot of shady
things at times you know what i mean a
lot yeah i was so happy like for me um
[Music]
you know
but also sometimes someone like enjoy
doing it
i have a co-worker sometime that
just like
take a fight when it's not necessary i'm
like bro you have to like in this job
you have to fight only if it's necessary
i fight for money i don't fight for free
and then when you fight at the street
most of the time you get hurt you know i
got weapons and you know yeah
what i want is like go there
do my job
collect my money go home come back next
next day that's it i don't want to go
home and find eyes to put on something
instead of like sleep i'm tired it's
like seven or eight a.m in the morning
i've been up all night long and the only
thing that i want is to go lay in my bed
yeah
and you mentioned earlier about now that
you're in the position that you're in
you're thinking about the future and
being able to provide for children
do you imagine a little francis one day
is that is that something you want to be
do you want to be a father and have a
family and all of that of course yeah of
course oh that has always been my
my dream really yeah how do you think
you'll be as a father a great father
yeah
yeah why because i love kids i love
i love
i always love kids i was a babysitter
when i was a kid really
because i was so good with kids like
when uh
moms around like having problems with
their kids crying or they want to do
something or go somewhere
i would just hear this nice voice like
francis then i'm like oh somebody need a
babysitter
then i'll just go
take a baby they'll do whatever they do
i will handle the baby doesn't matter
how hard the baby is
to deal with he's crying or whatever i
would play with him do everything until
you get exhausted angels
you've got a lot of patience then i just
enjoy playing with them yeah you know
like i was a kid
i think like maybe four to five years
old i don't remember very well and i
will always like go places with my mom
and i will see kids one day i we were in
the bus then i saw a kid
so every time that i saw baby i'm just
so excited so i saw a kid and then i
went to just like crappy baby
and then my mom like she hit my hands
like they don't touch people baby like
that
and you know
i kind of like get upset like damn
what does that even mean
then
for there from there i just think that i
want my own baby
but i was a kid
so i i asked like okay at what age they
can have
a baby they tell me like 20 about 20. so
my entire life i've been waiting for 20
years to have a baby
by the time i get close to 20 like 80
i'm like oh it's not that easy to have
it's not as simple
as i thought to have a baby yeah [__] i
know
no big francis and garner the babysitter
unbelievable i wasn't big this big
women everywhere will be listening to
this thing and you can have my baby i'll
tell you you look after my baby no
problem fair play with it did you hear
um kane velasquez the story about him uh
that's come out recently where allegedly
his child
was abused at play school
he heard about it they arrested the guy
who
who was abusing his child
but they let the guy go and came
velasquez went chasing after him did you
hear about this yeah came velasquez had
it gone
i think he tried shooting at the car
now came velasquez is uh in jail
ironically they let out the pedophile
but they won't let out cain velasquez
um who did what any father would do
you fought cain you shared the octagon
with him he was a former champion a
great champion how does this make you
feel the story
well um i think many men uh in his shoes
would have done the same thing
i think i would have been in the same
position
because like just imagine it
you know it's just hard to just sit down
i'm like okay
okay these guys out there
set free
i think they should have keeping in jail
you know
until like maybe
his anger came down if the family gets
certain and kind of like thing like okay
maybe he's kind of like pay his due
you know uh for what he have done
but to set him up uh
that quick was
i would have done the same thing bro
like
that's not that's something that every
father father would do
you know protect your family that's what
they you live for when you have a child
your goal is to protect them
at any cost even at the cost of your
life your own life
so yeah
and i think uh
he
shouldn't have any regret because if
he's to start over
it's something that you don't think
about it is instantly it's a feeling you
know
like uh
i don't know the crazy thing about the
justice system is is the system
we could say in velasquez
in jail longer than the guy
who did all that's the problem the guy
should stay in jail yeah and we should
avoid this problem you know most of the
time uh
in cameroon for example if you have a
car accident and uh kill somebody
even if you wasn't you weren't wrong
they will put you in jail for like i
think six months
this is not for
to blame you but it's at some point i
think it's like to protect you
because regardless
there is some family
out there that are hurt
and sometimes they want to
avenge they want to blame somebody
and that could be you
you know even though
you weren't wrong you know so
i mean
it's not fair
but sometimes yes they should keep you
away you know yeah i bet people drive
carefully in cameroon
oh no
they drive very bad
really
oh god no people walk carefully in
cameroon because if you don't walk
carefully
yeah you get picked up by the car wow
back to the
to the fury fight if we do this with
with ufc gloves
very small gloves obviously it's it's a
different game for fury he he obviously
blocks a lot of things with his those
big gloves that they use do you feel
like that will give you
the the chance to connect with him in a
way that other people couldn't
i think there's nothing different
there's not that much difference in it
no there's not because it's still going
to be
if it's
it's gonna be a boxing rule
you know
and uh we're trying to like compromise
find a compromise but there's not so
much because if we add a leg kick
he's gonna have a very very bad night
if we add a takedown or whatever or mma
rules
it's going to be
we can now talk about like the murder
because he's not like wow
he's not even able to defend himself
on that ground do you see him wrestling
with um
oh forget it tarantile yeah everybody
can wrestle you know
but how much you can wrestle
professionally he's very different in
his build he's he's he's made for like
the grappling as he's a he's very much a
boxer yeah in that sense yeah yeah so
what would your prediction be for a
fight against tyson fury like that uh
regardless i mean walking into this
fight depending of the rules i know he's
not like my crown i know tyson is a
great fighter and it's going to be very
hard for me basically like if i'm
joining him on his sport you know buster
i believe that
i have
i have something
to make to still make him
have a bad night have a days of a loss
so i think you hit harder than a wild my
prediction
is like
knocking out
because that's what i was trying to do
yeah you know i would my whole training
come i was just trying to be collect
don't go crazy don't throw don't be very
wild
and trying to be accurate because i'm
sure
i don't care how tough he is
if i hit
he's gonna feel it
it's funny because with the usic and
anthony joshua fight for example
everyone says you don't box a boxer you
fight a boxer and you're a fighter so i
think that there's a a great deal of of
interest going to be in this fight
because you can rough it up you can do
things that other people can't do you
know what i mean and you've got power
that i don't think he's even with johnny
wilder
being
uh deontay wilde was like 35 pounds
lighter than you you know he's like a
smaller guy and fury like to use uh he's
a uh
he likes
uh dirty boxing yeah if you see the
second i think was the second fight
against deonte walder he came out bigger
and right away that at the moment that i
saw him bigger i know exactly like what
he was doing i know he's going to wait
the until while they're down and that's
exactly what he's doing yeah he was just
leaning on him
and he was there on the wall there
carrying a fury on top of him
for two rounds he was exhausted bro
you know skinny little legs couldn't
handle it and he was doing the same
thing yesterday with dylan white like
just laying on him and like get dylan
white frustrated i saw the referee uh
blame dylan why like twice
but fury was very sneaky about it most
of the time
fury was the one initiating the action
and the long one get frustrated
frustrated and re react back
and then get blamed by the
free yeah
so but i think that's something first of
all that's something that won't work
with me because if you're trying to
daily boxing me or to weigh on me i
think i'm gonna take advantage on that
and uh by the way i think uh
i'm gonna try to
just you know i know how i would push it
or do something
i think if fury goes on the canvas two
three time
four on the canvas even though he didn't
get hit
it's going to take a little bit of
energy out of him
i mean i've i've met uh tyson uh the
great man himself and um
you're one of the few humans who is you
know bigger and stronger than him you
know what i mean and that's that's going
to be an interesting he's a very good
boxer though oh yeah he's a very clean
boxer absolutely he's he's fantastic
he's the he's the greatest of the
generation is outstanding yeah if if you
were given the option of
jon jones type or tyson fury
um money
let's say the money is the same
what fight interests you the most
why do i need an option why i can have
both
yes that
i have an option to have both okay
i'm going for both
i respect it i got uh one question left
which is
how would you like to be remembered how
would i like to be remembered
as a free man
who did whatever you want to do
legend you know i love it annette
uh
put my name in the sport do you remember
you know
maybe you know as mohammed ali maybe
yeah but somewhere
under there
you're you're doing it you're doing it
uh ladies and gentlemen that was francis
in gonu on the true jordi podcast the
ufc undisputed heavyweight champion of
the world
thank you
hey
legend
thank you francis